yeah different style eric bishop you
talk about eric who you know he's doing
what he's doing and you said if he would
have continued you know at one point you
guys are competing those guys are about
to lose bankruptcy all this stuff what
is the biggest difference between eric
and the way vince led
and marketed and told story what was the
difference well i think more than
anything and this was what was great
when bishop was running wcw even we were
doing great it was constant conflict
with the office meaning like
to turner people who were owned by ted
turner not ted but their people looked
down at wrestling
and when vince was fighting for his life
his whole companies are wrestling
superstars you know he took away lord
wrestling whatever you know sports
entertainers
it's his company it's his lifeline it's
his legacy it's everything and eric
didn't have that
if he could have been doing it on his
own who knows what would have happened
but you know you know when you work in
the corporate world you know you know
you've been all through that and it's so
hard then there's the jealousy thing and
you know all that when it's your company
and it's your brand
yes like and vince is the really the one
with hulk that
changed the whole format by the way you
know who who gets a lot of credit for
that story you just told dana white
because dana she's only a 10 owner of
the company
and dana was able to work you know
politics wme two owners came they bought
it for two million he got 10
and he was still able to move it up even
though it's not his company he's only a
10 guy the company it's not like he's 51
there's a difference between sure dana
and vince but dana still was able to
pull off the product which product to
the audience that doesn't i'm going to
show something here on the internet i
want these guys to see on youtube but
which one do you do you think ufc
today's surpassed
the audience and the eyeballs that
wrestling gets or do you think wrestling
is still ahead of ufc i think that ufc
would be bigger at this point because i
think it's very cyclical wrestling is
it's up and it's down and it's really
like it's harder now
to really understand how many people are
watching and give you an example um and
this was genius so everybody thought it
was like oh god what a waste of time wwe
network you know oh they're out they're
losing money they're this they're that
and everything
well i guess it was two years ago vince
leased
not sold but leased
the network
to peacock
for one billion dollars
for five years lease leased
they don't own [ __ ]
they are using because they what is the
most important thing on any whether it's
paramount peacock content a thousand
percent well now we've got a ton of
different shows it looked like when
vince was gonna you know wwf
was gonna trade to wwe oh my god they're
they've ruined his brand and they spent
all these years you know and vince
fought for it didn't get it
best thing ever happened to him this
time i'll use an example of this a
second but
so many times
what looks like the worst thing to ever
happened to you
can be the best if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]